The joe rogan experience.
Yeah.
You know,
homelands,
a good show.
No habit.
I gave up after loss on tea.
Just don't watch television.
I don't watch anything they show and real three or a flat screen Elvis.
The TV,
I only watch.
That's it.
I'm done throwing and watch.
It's not a good thing.
It's not any virtue.
Like I watched bigfoot hunter,
I watched fucking two episodes.
I had DVR
finding big foot or something and it's like a series where they have like more
than one hour.
The first episode they'd be like,
yeah,
we're not going to find them.
Well,
it's awesome.
No,
the best part about it is the beginning of the guys.
I've been hunting Sasquatches for 25 years.
I'll quit now.
Quit quitting that.
You haven't even got a video of one and crazy as hell.
It's like,
you know,
it's like,
hey,
you know how those go shows are really not realistic.
Like they never really find a ghost.
This what if we did it with Sas,
but what's next?
Like Tuba cobre sure.
If they can sell it,
they would.
They would have it.
It's a,
it's a fun show to watch though,
because it's so stupid.
I mean,
first of all,
everyone has a video that they want you to analyze.
It may have been a Sasquatch,
so they have to recreate the scene in the video.
It looks sweet.
It looks so silly because the people knew exactly where the car was and this is
the tree.
And so they line it up on the camera and then they have this big guy named Bobo
who kind of looks like a big foot.
And he goes out there and he does exactly what,
and he's always way bigger than the big foot in the video.
So it always proves that it wasn't really that day.
Oh,
I see here.
Or You were big foot.
Yep.
Out of pig foot a season one.
Season two.
They replaced me.
There was like a contract.
Do you remember when I wanted to make us more empathetic and uh,
Harry and the Hendersons like a whole family lived with big foot.
You know,
why not?
She badgered her selfie to my kids.
I'm pretty sure.
I don't even trust dogs than,
I don't know.
This guy's got a fucking big foot hanging out with his kids.
He probably told these stupid humans a thing or two about love.
I
hurry in the Henderson,
there's never been a real good bigfoot movie.
How about that?
Nobody has ever stepped up and it's not like,
uh,
the bar's been set that high.
The bar is incredibly low.
The bar is all fraudulent videos.
Yeah.
That's the closest thing to a big foot move and I would think after like season
one,
there's a lot of people that watch the show and they're like,
why not?
Like I think you should
never been up.
There's,
I mean there was like this is a really bad ones.
The seventies or some swamp thing,
monster guy.
But there's never been a movie,
a good movie about a bunch of people that encounter big foot.
Why?
How is that possible that you have such a,
a folklore that is completely permeated society.
He's not there.
No one's ever made,
not sexy,
but I made a movie about finding bigfoot.
That's amazing.
That's true.
That's incredible.
We're really,
when you think about how popular it is,
you would movie would be human.
The movie ideas they're doing,
they're just,
okay.
It's like based on a matchbook.
Yeah.
Like,
so you'd think they'd have big fun romantic comedies when you hear some romantic
comedy premise and you like what?
I don't understand.
Finally meet again at 60.
You know,
I sometimes feel like I just established a consciousness when I was like 30
because like romantic comedies,
like I,
you know,
I was so dumb I think in my twenties that like when,
it would be like,
uh,
you know,
Meg Ryan and Billy Crystal,
like Harry met Sally.
Like to me that was just a movie.
I didn't consider that a romantic comedy,
which it was,
but now it's like this genre that is always existed,
but they just kind of like,
just churn out these,
just like those romantic code existed.
Movies were when a woman got mouthy,
the made gave her the back of her hand.
Yup.
Back of his hand.
Right.
That's what they used to do to the moon.
Alice.
Yeah.
All that stuff.
That was really good old days.
Billy Crystal fucked us.
Billy Crystal fucked up,
fucked us in.
Harry met Sally.
I tried to be tried to be manly.
He tried to like be the best.
Oh,
I'd say a couple of,
and then he caved that are sleepless nights because he,
so you'll see when Harry met Sally,
Harry met Sally is like,
it's like a sad ending to you.
You're like,
you know what?
It's weird.
You know,
you're the comedy policemen.
No,
I'm not.
She called me that before the Improv and I told you that would be very
uncomfortable.
That makes you uncomfortable.
Not really,
but I only,
I looked,
I step in for one piece of civil unrest.
That's something I've never done anything since.
Well,
there's something about that whole situation with Leno and I don't know which
eye at all and uh,
but it's,
you know,
if there was a Joe Rogan of that generation,
maybe to go and,
uh,
explain it,
that's why you,
that's our new show.
You look for bigfoot
comedy kind of a,
okay.